circle of life just like the movie you
cried over last night that's beauty in
the [ __ ] movie and can I just say
something right now yeah she goes the
beauty abuse I go who's playing the lion
the Beast that's a that's a lion why
it's not a lion it's like a horn like it
looks more like a [ __ ] goat than it
does a lot never seen nobody in the
beasts right but this is all I swear to
god I've never seen it in fact I want to
tell it to people right now all right
when I dated Jasmine Trahan mmm who's I
dated her for like six months
right she goes let's go see this new
play way and it was called the lions
king lion lion like lions king lion lion
king whatever Jesus the Lions king am i
right please give so I go I go I go
there was they came up from behind me
like people in costume another part yeah
right and that was gone this is great I
go they should make this into a movie
and then she goes she goes it is a
[ __ ] movie so I don't anything about
it but I know that Beauty and the beasts
are is a movie cartoon right but I
already know what it's about without
even seeing it it's princess okay there
princess but listen to me no it's not
small lady I'll tell all right and I
don't see if he gets let me see if I get
it right and she she falls in love with
a beast a lion right and then they love
so hard that he turns back into a human
oh my god do I have the gist right you
have the ending right right so why the
third do I need a [ __ ] say yeah
initially what oh my she was a prisoner
and she gave him a third well initially
her father was a prison Maurice crazy
old Maurice no you don't know
you don't know chip you don't know what
house you one more [ __ ] with me money
[ __ ] candy yeah yeah great she do
Urban Bob I did it again urban Bobby
Bobby Cox Disney and I listen okay you
you saw that movie as a kid with your
Papa and I know that you miss your papa
and it makes it breaks my heart that he
passed it does I've always wanted to
meet him you know when he is like to me
his her dad is that guy from the pork
wear of a the beverage whiskey oh that
guy huh yeah like a world traveler and
stuff like that and I feel bad that he's
gone and and I guess I do feel apologize
to you for not hugging you last night
because that was a personal thing she
was really crying and I did laugh in her
face and I just feel real terrible about
it you know and um you know what
it doesn't matter because we have each
other
he's full circle kiss kiss kiss and
you're right I'm gonna get more
proactive after Destiny's done and I you
know what
[Music]